hey everyone
we're back we're now in
la fortuna
near the volcano arenal
still with tristan tyler blake
said a good episode about from infinity
to infinity on our
drive down here while we're looking for
land for a regenerative community
run a nice little hike before we go
visit another potential
location later today
tristan what are you feeling like
exploring
conversation i'm very open to
uh pretty much any conversation and we
had a great one coming up here
yep i think maybe we can continue the
threat of that
this morning um i was really
interested in solving a problem with
categorizing cells cataloging cells and
the different types of
um you know cell types and
the types of receptors on them um
and you know there's a lot of complexity
here a lot of different types of
astrocytes and glial and you know
blastocysts and all these different
endocrine cells and they all have their
own subcategories
it's almost impossible to really uh
visualize this or experience it until
you you map it
so this mapping technology is something
really fun that's been on my mind that's
been on your mind
uh maybe we can that's cool i like
mapping technology as a
place to
kick us into conversation
yeah it also plays into our previous
conversation a lot too
because
you have both the mapping technology for
infinity and for infinity so
for infinity as tristan started
describing
you can take something like a stem cell
and you can see all the different
cells that it differentiates into so you
have heart cells you have muscle cells
you have neurons
you have bone cells skin cells etc
immune cells and so
neuronal cells yep and so
there's a
this is not only a complex way that
form evolves in
this creation and
to map that and create a greater
understanding of the way to heal
pathologies that develop
prevent pathologies from even developing
to gain insights into the exact code of
life in the way that it
promulgates and
expands into more complex systems and
flowers new species
all that kind of stuff is great and then
on the infinity side
the mapping technologies
are a lot about
seeing this
style of analyzing form
as one example
of the
analysis of a creation
so here we have a fundamental unit it's
like a cell in biology
and in another exploratory creation of
ours
a different fundamental unit
arises
an information cell yeah and information
so
that's what that's probably what ai is
like kind of the early
uh information cells like i guess
packets
you know um yeah software is the uh
kind of the nervous system and uh uh
these languages are for different um
this thing does seem like uh it's uh
some sort of computational organism
and uh yeah it's a good way to put it
yeah and i get this intuition that uh
uh there are systems that feed off of
our computational
capabilities of our brains like
you know different i think even
organisms live
on top of our conscious
computational sort of uh horsepower
right so something hacks into it and
uses it uh in order to compute for
it we use machines
to accelerate our compute and to scale
right and i um if you anywhere you look
you see life
everywhere in every direction it doesn't
matter how small
or probably how big so
i you know it's fun to think about these
computational organisms like even maybe
what is a a corporation
or a government but not some sort of
networked organism
uh with its own you know you meet some
of the people that represent these
entities and they go they go into
into representation mode of let's say a
company like
you know ibm or something like that they
really
take on the form of expressing
the company's wishes through themselves
so and it seems that where is this
computational identity
stored in the brain that i am a
i am a hybrid of co right co-network i
am
hybridized with this computational
organism it
may be a parasite but it's a it's a fun
parasite to be
you know engaged with so that's the
as though the
most macro level absolute or highest
infinity is both intelligent and
comprehensive
and we act as the artificial
intelligence the machine learning
in this creation to understand this
finite expression of itself
and then in this one
there's a
there's a way to create mapping
technologies
that drive these
power lost style insights so you want to
gather the
most fundamental units
like cells in biology periodic table
subatomic particles
star forma stellar formation kind of
like stellar catalogs
yep and then that gives
infinity its ability
to most efficiently
create a mapping technology for finity
for this
creation there are two different uh
instruments to like uh like there's
instruments for observing
nature and reality right a microscope
observes microscopic things uh
an electron microscope observes the
electron uh
um scale right the order of magnitude
so um observing spiritual
uh kind of um states
it requires its own technologies you
know and
and that's an interesting thing to kind
of like map out that
now what are those uh mapping tools that
currently exist
so philosophy would be one of them right
some there are some many religious
traditions that also
uh take a a a decent dent
you know to put a dent into kind of that
space but
what are the modern tools that are
useful for this can software be used to
map
the identity or or or meaning or you
know these kinds of
esoterics yeah we talked about it a bit
before our first
podcast was that we're using technology
like
hrv heart rate variability eeg fmri
we have these different ways to measure
coherence versus
cortisol
so you can be in a state of symmetry you
can be in a state of harmony in a state
of balance you can also
juxtapose that with being in a state of
stress
being in a decoherent state
and that's very sort of visibly
seen as something like this
where you have on one side of the
spectrum on a more maybe
decoherence state you have somebody
that's a little bit
you know more like
i'm so stressed out i need to do this i
need to do that yeah
and then on the other side of the
spectrum is something that's a little
bit more like
isn't this life beautiful it's in this
life sacred
it's in this life divine how do we
maximize human potential
right so these sort of two poles
that are typically called like ego or
contracted
energy or feeling separation
feeling depression anxiety
versus on the other side it's like
feeling enlightenment it's like feeling
empowerment
it's like feeling a divine harmonic
connection to life and to
the true nature of reality i don't think
depression is the opposite
of enlightenment
in the sense of um first of all i think
it requires
uh um really challenging states in order
to achieve
uh even the first steps towards the
direction of enlightenment
like you need to pass through certain
filters um
you know of of your wandering of your
struggles you need to struggle with
yourself you need to conquer certain
fears
uh before you can uh
know thyself right so uh and i think the
depression is um i think it's
characterized
as kind of like a bad or you know bad
state
um it's just a state that's reminding
you that you
aren't completely um where you need to
be it's a it's an
unconscious uh sort of uh
intelligence it's an emotional guidance
it's an unconscious intelligence
that's trying to uh indicate that
something is wrong
you know your arm hurts that's not your
arm being a dick
it's your arm telling you hey fix this
and the moment you listen and you uh
you have the tools to deal with that
right
uh you do it and all of a sudden the arm
pain goes away
um or if you understand your body as a
system as an anatomical
structure then you can start even
influencing your body's development
you know so so studying some stem cells
right now is very
interesting i think the time has come to
ethically um kind of
you know this this technology is falling
out of the sky in in the same way that
asteroid does right these are
these are innovation asteroids in a
sense
and there's a couple of them crispr
stem cell technologies right these 3d
printing
um all these decentralized approaches so
many things flying out of the sky that
are going to fundamentally transform
the human condition uh even some of the
technologies that i'm personally working
on the mapping tech right
for mapping uh not only scientific
phenomena and like the
chemistry and material sciences and all
that but also mapping
uh the mind and the sh and the shadow if
if you want to call it that right and
and reinterpreting it
with different neural tilts perspectives
um so that's the first time i've heard
that term it's a cool one
a neuro tilt yeah it's like a
it's like a angle like a neural angle
yeah that kind of falls also into that
spectrum of ego to enlightenment as well
your neuro tilt if you're more
enlightened is usually more peace and
more joy
and if you're more egotistical it's
usually trying to extract
from other people um things like that
and
that extraction thing that vampirical
thing can we can we kind of uh
pin on that for a sec yeah it'd be
interesting to also unpack how to map
from not only the analysis of form
but also the analysis of like we've been
talking about now these
states of consciousness these neural
tilts these
neural angles these states of
dissonance versus harmony lenses
they're like lenses of perspective so uh
you can adopt the visual
um perspective of say something and i've
been doing this a lot for for my work
and for my
even kind of you know uh explorations my
projects you can map the world as a
social network would right you could see
it through the lens or the eyes of a
social network and
and that gives you a networked
perspective of the world you could also
take on the bacterial and viral
um perspective you could really think
like a virus because you have to
understand these things
and uh viruses are simply delivery
mechanisms
beautiful it's like the ups but what's a
biological form these are supply chain
and logistics
experts and man if you even
learn to interact with them you can you
can start delivering medicine and
therapies destroying cancers
you know delivering antigens and special
proteins to cells directly
it's the programming of biology it's
very very exciting virology
yeah it's super exciting i like how you
called it the
ups that's funny that's a really good
way to put it
yeah supply chain yeah the viruses are
supply chain experts they uh
they try they use us as transportation
like we are big ships for them
and we transport them around yeah that's
the only purpose we have and
uh i've been reading a lot of books on
virology and it's
kind of just by shipping
all the produce around the world uh
you're taking
bacteria and little microbiomes and
stuff
from one place of the earth to the other
and that's having significant
consequences on local
genetic diversity and and it can kill
crops it can
damage ecosystems you can introduce
pests and
parasites into the system and we're
we're only starting to learn right now
that we even have a relationship with
these masters of this current earth
they're bacteria we are we are guests
here
in this hotel and we need to act
a little bit more uh like we can't trash
the room
yeah we've been talking about this for a
while now this sort of three and a half
billion year evolutionary ascent for
especially these single-celled
bacterial organisms
and acting as vehicles for them
right now in our gut microbiome
it's a really fascinating one that we've
talked about on the show for a couple of
years
yeah that's good i like mapping
technologies both for
finity for understanding form
and also for in a sense
for infinity
which is mapping both
the
subjective realm of consciousness
states of ego versus enlightenment
and then also in terms of
this being just one of our
expressions one of our creations
when you're obsessed with infinity and
you've never tasted
infinity you don't know your true nature
when you've tasted infinity
and you know it and you live from it
then you understand the true nature of
infinity
and then you can be a more coherent
agent in the finite
and then the mapping technologies work
for both
the finite they work for
the consciousness and they work for
the infinite do you want to give them a
understanding of mapping technologies
kind of more more like yeah practical
appliances
that's a good point so for the mapping
technologies for the finite
it would be things like the subatomic
particles
so you have the standard model and you
have that
entire table
you have your bosons you have your
fermions
you have your periodic table
of elements is another mapping
technology for finity you have like we
talked about the beginning of the
episode you have
the fundamental unit in biology of the
cell
and you have all these different
kingdoms that it gets to explore in
your bacteria you have plants you have
animals and then all these different
differentiations we were talking about
even inside of the human body
so you have a bunch of maps for finity
like we just mentioned
and likely some of these maps for finity
end up
having interplay
with infinity because in a sense the
same phenomena that you see in biology
of
mitosis is likely going to
continue in our next creations
because it's just such a fundamental
process to have a
a cell cycle and a cell checkpoint when
it feels comfortable enough to divide
that's such a it's a perennial
finite process that mirrors
infinite processes and so there's
something similar there and then so
that's mapping for finity
then there's mapping for consciousness
which could be something like
heart rate variability eeg
electroencephalography fmri functional
magnetic resonance imaging
tracking your unconscious thoughts and
labeling them so like the actual
the state of awareness that you do have
to have like
some people have 4k resolution
you know experience some people have
maybe even 8k some
super like i think hyper sensitives or
hyper fantasia whatever that is right
hyper imagination
um and some people have 1080p and uh
kind of your data metabolism you can
only take so much oh yeah yeah
yeah you can only you can only
um take in so much data and now we're
getting more and more data
you can take in more and more so that's
a good point
it's almost like with the ego you might
be contracted down to like a 360p
perspective yeah so with the ego you
might only know
that the only thing that you can do
right
now is to have a a
a perspective of being kind of
inflammatory
like you have to prove your point you
have to
convince the other person of what you
see
this type of stuff versus when you maybe
upgrade to 480p 720p
you sort of maybe relax a little bit
more into understanding that
the other person also has a unique
perspective that you could learn from
and then as you upgrade yourself to
1080p
4k 8k that you gain more and more of an
understanding that all 8 billion
perspectives on the planet have their
own little
hermeneutic or partial truth to them
yeah but some but some have a much
higher resolution
uh a signaling apparatus right
so so that's what good speakers they can
uh create a crafter information
cell or unit and horizontally transfer
it to you
and you can download and when you open
the file it's well organized it's a
it's a package that you can now use as a
tool you could you could you can store
it
right so these are these information
cells that that these uh teachers
put together and the highest resolution
ones it's kind of like
in order to so let's say we want to
watch a
you know high quality hd movie we need a
hard drive
a sufficient hard drive to store that
and a sufficient screen resolution to
display all the pixels
otherwise it's going to freeze it's
going to it's going to be a
incomplete experience and so
i think that the human brain is
kind of not um overclocking
yet we can overclock by hybridizing with
networked technologies with
computational technologies
these things plug right into our neural
structures and we can
boost and broadcast the signal and
mitigate the noise
i was thinking about this the other day
like for that for
for uh you know kind of like uh just the
average
there i'm uh devices are already
increasing the resolution oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i am the
signal in kind of this average sort of
milieu right
i i try to act as the signal but i find
that when i'm an interviewer or when i'm
dealing with very
very uh um intelligent and beautiful
people i like to kind of create a little
bit of
noise in order to in order to
hone their signal right
in order to actually create a little bit
of noise it's funny
i went to this one lecture on i think
was by the ieee
on um information like electrical
circuits and stuff
and you by boosting noise in the system
you can actually increase
its uh sensitivity it's precision
there's something very interesting in uh
communications and like
uh that whole
that whole field electronics
you know
it has interesting parallels to the
memory and
like the computer memory and information
transfer and stuff
it has really good parallels for how to
store our memories and then pull them
and act upon them so you have a very
good thought a moment of inspiration
right
eureka moment how do you get access to
that
spiritual awakening kind of recognition
thought
yeah this requires significant balance
to
there you go nice
now so these are mapping technologies
essentially to
um be able to take any system
and to reveal its
really kind of complex nature right so
you think about
uh quantum mechanics and you're like oh
it's pretty like it's a lot of words and
there's a lot of spins going on and all
this stuff but but funny enough if you
actually map
it and you you kind of have to have a
really serious
uh diligence for sort of information
quality like you you can't put in you
have to
you have to be very careful with your
data right
so so that's kind of interesting and
then it reveals itself it becomes very
simple
once you see it
yeah so what are the spiritual what are
the spiritual maps that could be
evolved and some of that you have more
personal work done what are some of
these spiritual maps that you've
seen that can help as a tool set
for somebody who's looking to a find
meaning and purpose
uh discover beauty or or see it
hidden in you know in in different
places inside of people or inside of
nature
what are some of these tools that you've
been working with or creating
yeah let's continue viewing it from
a macro level umbrella style
visualization of the topic that we're
talking about so
overarching you could say is mapping
technologies and then
underneath of mapping technologies you
can kind of create three categories one
of them is
finity or analyzing form which we gave
the example of
subatomic particles the periodic table
we gave the matter matter matter the
fundamental union biology the cell so
for
matter and so there's that
and then there's a mapping technology
for
consciousness spirituality awareness
from the ego to more enlightened states
leveraging hari variability egf mri like
we've been talking about
and there's the general sort of
expression of that
as a state that's a little bit more
contracted versus something that's more
relaxed and more expansive something
that's more peaceful and joyful
and then the utility social template
social
kind of uh civilizational models of
cooperation like
powerful and new vocabularies for really
um high bandwidth uh
information transfer and cooperation
protocols
that's kind of one of the things yeah so
one of the main aspects to the utility
of having a
a mapping technology for consciousness
spirituality awareness is that
what you get is you get a more
healthy and happy relationship with
yourself
with your family with your friends with
your community
with the world
and there's also a lexicon or a
nomenclature there's
a categorization that then
makes it so that you can actually put a
word
to the north star of
doing gym repetitions
in order to
be less egotistical and more enlightened
and so then there's the third category
in the mapping technology so again
finity was one
consciousness was another infinity is
another
and so in infinity the mapping
technologies
are very much like a big question mark
but one thing that we know about it
for sure via direct experience is that
this finite creation is just
one expression of the infinite is just
one expression of the absolute of the
highest
of source of god of brahman of tao
and
by the way i i believe this is a maybe
simple
expression of that is to
explain it in the sense of an analogy
this is one way to paint a blank canvas
and that there's endless ways to paint a
blank canvas
and that we will never come to the end
of ways of painting a blank canvas just
like we'll never come to the end of ways
to arrange musical notes into a song
we will never come to the end of ways to
combine food into
recipes we will never come to the end of
ways of
vibrating our vocal cords to make
languages and so we'll never come to the
end of our
exploration and so in that mapping for
the infinite
it's very much like recognizing this
finite
as but one exploration
of r so there's sort of three different
like mapping
technology subcategories to the macro
level mapping
which is infinity consciousness
infinity so i personally believe
objective subjective and infinite yeah i
personally believe that that
scientific instrumentation and just what
the tools we have now
will be sufficient to like map all of
that
and uh um you know consciousness i think
neuroscience has it pretty much
uh kind of is honing in on
the the clearest understanding
of perception so far and how it works
kind of like all the
cellular and neuronal firings that take
place
to make that happen right so so
definitely
neurosciences the neural correlates of
consciousness
are getting mapped out and we're on the
way
and we're getting closer and closer and
i i think lies
in there the answer to
what is consciousness and how does it
work i i think the spiritual one
it can be a good sort of a metaphorical
guide and a map of metaphors that you
can
use for um
insights into how to map it in in a
robust
way with uh with the current tools that
we have
eeg and all these other signaling and
things that we
um you know are developing now like
different types of
uh uh spectrometers for for brain kind
of like to analyze the brain
um heat maps and stuff like we're
getting really cool new
um magnets
and lasers so it's pretty exciting
because we're going to get much higher
resolution images of
neural activity and then we'll be able
to map it and understand
kind of where does consciousness
sit how is it formed and what are the
barriers to it but but in this world in
this physical space there are
certainly barriers to perception
um you can train ai to show you what it
looks like
to see the world from the perspective of
a snake or a
dog you know or a bat
um it would be cool to have retinal
implants that can do that
that's a stem cell thing that's later
that's coming that's on the way you'll
be able to take on perspectives
in our lifetime so i guess that's cool
what do you think of that do you think
oh i love that yeah i'm a huge fan
that's an exciting one because it sort
of begins taking on the perspective of
the absolute or the highest because
as it expresses itself via this
creation typically what happens is that
like we've been talking about the ego
starts off at just i only have this
atlas perspective and that's it
that's all that i care about i need to
feel
safe i need money i need
to extract from relationships and
experiences and
that kind of a thing and then the shift
happens where it goes
well maybe maybe what tristan's
perspective
is pretty cool maybe i should you know
give it a go and then
empathy happens and then you you add a
second perspective where you learn more
about tristan's life you learn more
about
where he came from how he built up his
perspective
what nuances he asked his perspective
that you could learn from and then you
go
well what about sarah's perspective i
want to learn about sarah's perspective
and then you go what about michelle's
perspective
and so then you start sort of building
yourself out to this like eight billion
humans at the same time
and then you can hold all eight billion
human perspectives
and then like tristan mentioned a moment
ago then you have
a snake seeing an infrared and you have
bats that use
sonar and dolphins as well and
you have all these other bees with
ultraviolet you have all these different
ways of this electromagnetic spectrum
and perception
and consciousness boosting that's that's
so you can hold that
entire synthetic consciousness 10
million species of perspectives on the
planet
at the same time i wouldn't want that
and then in a sense you get a
really really highest
resolution possible sort of taste for
what the absolute is tasting
through its analysis of this finite
so this is an interesting question right
so you have a team of
of a thousand people um let's just say
standard distribution of intelligence
and capability
uh and grit and all these things do you
want to take
the inside of all hundred for some
average doubt kind of opinion on what to
do a decision science
or do you isolate the top three decision
makers and uh
decide what and and have them kind of uh
map out the system and then make a
critical decision
i'm of the camp of i don't care about
the opinion of the people that are wrong
honestly
even if even if like i actually only
care about what's accurate and what's
true
um because there's many ways to be wrong
and there's very
subtle and few ways to be very right
and i would pro me personally like uh i
would like to
always kind of i don't care about 8
billion perspectives i care about
800 that are the closest
to the source of knowledge you see
what do you think about that because you
see the other one you you actually want
to take in everybody's perspective and
that's interesting
well the way to sort of combine what
we're
talking about is that you you both want
to hold
the absolutes perspective of how a
hummingbird comes and just
enjoys the nectar from a flower
as well as you want to hold the
perspective of what is currently being
discussed at the world economic forum at
davos
because you want to know what it's like
to have a conversation between
the
alex carp from
palantir having a conversation with
angela merkel from germany
and you want to know what it's like for
a costa rican that
lives in a village of a hundred people
to barter
the beans that he's drawing
for the bananas that his local neighbor
is growing
and so the
power law of course takes into account
and it's gorgeous
and beautiful and yet there's this
beautiful
bird that's just circling in vortexes
above us right now
and the absolute is also experiencing
itself
as the bird right now that's
flying in these vortexes and exploring
what it's like to even be
that and so
[Music]
that's how to sort of synthesize
the costa rican farmer bartering might
have a little bit
less of a knowledge
in how to run a country of
10 million people yeah
but they may still be able to add
something quite interesting or effective
into the conversation
that around bartering or around
peace or around joy or around meeting
basic needs
or subjects like that that maybe
somebody that's
in a suit and tie that
stays in the four seasons hotels might
not
be seeing and so they both see things
that the other doesn't see and that's
why
holding a really
absolute perspective around trying to
intake the entire taste of the creation
is so beautiful it's unbelievable
you have so much to taste
you have to take yourself out of your
360p
perspective of this low resolution
style only atlas
uh
that's what you look like when you're
only focused on your perspective
and then when you at least gain a second
perspective you at least
hold two observers perspective
simultaneously that's why awareness
itself is impersonal
our source is the same
and then you take in 8 billion humans
perspectives then you take in all 10
million species perspectives and then
you start
tasting what the absolute tastes when it
makes these finite creations in an
exploratory fashion
and then we create mapping technology to
map
the finite again these very
subatomic particles chemistry elements
biological cells and then you have these
states of consciousness from ego to
enlightenment
like we discussed taking up to 8 billion
perspective simultaneously
up to 10 million species simultaneously
and then you have
the infinite then you have this is but
one of our creations
and that will never come to the end of
the different ways that we can
combine musical notes into a song we are
the eternal symphony
that endlessly plays and this is one
beautiful
song and you can think in terms of
states of consciousness that
the egotistical states are the ones that
are playing their musical instruments
out of tune
and i don't think so and the enlightened
ones are the ones that are playing more
in tune but it's all perfection
perfect i think ego is required for
certain
it's it's it's a it's a powder it's a
piece of the formula
and you it's not something that you
throw out it's like throwing out salt
you need to have it's kind of a salt and
then you have these periodic table of
emotions
so you have to mix different chemistries
and you get emotions you get exotic
emotions right you can craft these
experiences for yourself and others
um and the so you don't want to throw
out ego it's very
valuable it's not it's not throwing it
out it's that
the absolute when it manifests when we
manifest
this finite creation we use ego
as a 100 000
year old sort of primal limbic way
some of us use ego like that there's
people that transform ego
into very powerful pieces of art and
physical form like body as in
just to finish this thought the idea is
that the ego is
another way of explaining what it's like
for something that is infinite to
contract itself down into an
individuated perspective
and then that is what we use the word
ego to describe
and then when we talk about dissolving
the ego all we're talking about
is that contracted finite individuated
egoic perspective
relaxing and expanding itself back into
its infinitude
and then it can continue enjoying its
perspective from a place of knowing its
true nature
and so the ego is just a
word that we used to describe said
yeah i was asking you the other day like
i get it like freud's cool
you know all these guys are cool but is
it really how it works or
are these just words to describe things
that are uh indescribable if not
even not even there like how much of it
is uh
the contracted is totally there and then
we just use the word ego to describe it
the contracted is again the infinite
as it takes the perspective of an
individuated finite entity
feels like it doesn't know its true
nature it
feels forgetting it feels like it's
hiding
and then that's the game of seeking
seeking its own infinitude
seeking its remembrance of its true
nature that's
i believe that right there is
understanding biology like
like your purpose if you're looking for
a purpose in life
and if you if you don't have a purpose
then it's very simple
um you know you don't even have to
unlearn another purpose that's not even
that good
just go after the core which is what it
like how does life work what is the cell
how is how is uh biology and and
life such a resistance to entropy
how is it possible that this thing is
all this atp
circulating you know i listen to a lot
of spiritual people
they're very sweet friends of mine on
many occasions and
um you know and i i love this community
it's it's very
likes yoga as well um they
they talk about energy and i'm like yeah
yeah that's atp like yes
they got it they they intuitively got
the point
and now here's the actual uh chemical
mechanisms that and and physics
mechanisms that make
this quote-unquote energy possible yeah
yeah your cells and your body and your
blood and all this stuff it needs
atp in order to you know to do all those
little cellular
mechanisms the mechanics of of these
proteins and lipids and
carbohydrates so yeah atp is that thing
that you capture from the sun
it's the same thing that you know uh
chloroplasts make in
uh in plants and you know in these uh
other cell types so
these are just different words for the
same thing
but i believe that you can make
with the understanding of photosynthesis
the physical realm
you can actually plant plants and
understand what goes on and then uh
increase the photosensitivity and create
solar panels and whatnot from the
understanding
how is this spiritual energy
this is like i we've been talking about
this in the car and i really love
this area because i think this is the
intersection between science
and spirituality you know and uh and i
think both
have significant value uh science for me
has been very clear like the
definition of quantum is extremely clear
and every word belongs there
um but the definition from the
perspective of you know spirituality is
extremely
uh loose and uh
it is hard to back up it's very
metaphorical
so it's it's kind of more artistic than
it is uh practical useful
recognize that you know utility is a
value for me
but uh how do you feel about this you
know this so your
your spiritual kind of
depth what are you seeing in terms of
spirituality being able to solve
problems that i believe
science is capable of doing that it is
not what would you say is kind of some
of those things
well i just don't create a divide
between them in the first place
yeah so i don't create a divide between
science spiritual i don't create a
divide between infinity and infinity i
don't
no longer don't create a divide between
matter and consciousness but
we do create the
concessionary divides or juxtapositions
to be able to share with people things
like their true nature
because if you do think that you're just
a hairless monkey
that's on a rock orbiting a star that's
completely random and meaningless
then you're gonna behave completely
differently typically in a way that's
violent
rather than if you know your true nature
as infinite and you know your true
nature as we share our source that we
share our awareness
that we are the same exploratory
process that's happening and so then you
behave from a place of benevolence you
behave from a place of gratitude from a
place of peace
from joy and so you merge
science and spirituality you merge
consciousness and matter you merge
infinity and infinity
it's a very important subject right now
uh for me like
as a kind of uh you know somebody that
loves these
systems and uh mapping them um
i want the i would love for other people
to have access
to this uh these visuals these kind of
like frameworks
totally and to truly be able to
something that we're building
well yeah yeah and i kind of have this
theory that
uh unless you've struggled to understand
the nature of
the current reality you can't
even have a a sense for the spiritual
like your spirituality must be earned it
isn't something that you just feel or do
it's something that you need to struggle
through in order to
philosophy like okay you need to take
significant philosophy philosophical um
you know true you need to read you need
to go through you need to read a lot of
books you need to understand it so
achieving spirituality is a uh
is a is a journey like you can't just do
it just by feeling great
you know and that's kind of one of the
things that i want to share that it's
not supposed to be easy
it's supposed to hurt like working out
is supposed to feel unpleasant
until the last 10 where it feels great
we're in an alchemical transmutation
that's what the infinite exploring
is constant alchemical
transmutation an absolute perfection
that's endlessly perfecting
it's so cute can we can we take them on
a dance
so yeah so we're building out mapping
technologies right now
and we're going to take you we're going
to take you on a dance
um we
actually they're we're going to allow
them to join our
dance you guys can join our dance i'll
just
summarize yeah we're building mapping
technologies it's really exciting
keep in mind the sort of
ideas that we talked about on the
episode
around infinity
and mapping technologies for that
consciousness mapping technologies for
that
infinity mapping technologies for that
knowing your true
nature maximizing human potential
and we love you very much come join us
in this
dance party with the volcano with the
volcano
and we're gonna take you on uh yeah
leave it leave it little
let's let's uh leave it there we're
gonna kind of dance around
dance around all right we're gonna i'm
gonna dance over here
[Music]
me
[Music]
life is just a cycle in which it is
living in what's known
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
dance in the rain and fall in love
live every pain you have to have
nothing's the same your crooked power
be full again and fall in love
be full again and fall in love
be full again and fall in love
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
but what you can always do
will be is can help to make more
interesting and flip the normal boring
life you
had the only thing you
need to do is
dance in the rain and fall in love
live every pain you have to have
nothing's the same
again and fall in love
[Music]
dance in the rain and fall in
[Music]
is
[Music]
again
[Music]
again
[Music]
so
[Music]
i wonder who's behind
[Music]
the me and fall in love
live every pain you have to have
nothing's the same a crooked path
be full again and fall in love
be full again